hello your ting entertainment week
coming up on the show director Michael
Winterbottom on how the amanda knox
trial inspired his new film face of an
angel russell crowe who tells us about
stage fright and stepping behind the
camera for the water diviner a new
direction for the world's biggest boy
band as Dane quits and documentary maker
Nick Broomfield reveals la seedy
underbelly in his new film first let's
catch up on the week's entertainment
news there is flash photography coming
up Zayn Malik left one direction fans
devastated after quitting a band to be
what he described as a normal 22 year
old he says the decision feels right
Jeremy Clarkson was dropped by the BBC
as host of Top Gear following an
altercation with the show's producer
Angelina Jolie revealed she had surgery
to remove her ovaries as a preventive
measure against cancer Lil Chris the
star of reality show rock school died
aged 24 police are not treating the
death of the singer real name Chris
Hardman as suspicious James Corden one
American audiences over as he made his
debut as host of The Late Late Show it
was announced the sixth series of
Downton Abbey will be hits last Sam
taylor-johnson has said she won't direct
the sequels to Fifty Shades of Grey us
Network Fox has confirmed Mulder and
Scully will be back for six new episodes
of The X Files this summer and Joan
Collins received her dame hood from
Prince Charles for services to charity
and to discuss some of those stories as
entertainment journalist steve
hargreaves d great to see you now Zayn
Malik he quits one direction to be a
normal 22 yards normal who wants to be
normal I mean is this a good idea you
know I think I kind of did swung around
a little bit because initially everyone
said he's quit to go into obscurity and
just kind of I guess because of stress
yeah because of stress and it was this
kind of serious on something
underpinning it but we now know that he
he's kind of quit because he basically
wants to do his own thing musically so
he is working on solo material although
he says he's not going to rush it but
he's already been picture going to the
studio so there perhaps is a slightly
different reason
emerging from what we initially had and
zayn himself has said in the interview
that he gave he's spoken to the Sun
spoken to the Sun newspaper yeah who got
this interview with him and he said that
basically he just did want to do anymore
and hadn't wanted to do it for a while
so I think what we're seeing and we see
it quite a lot they're 22 year old guys
having to get on stage and seeing pop
songs two kids a lot of 22 year old
guides don't like this sort of music so
I think it's just someone being a bit
more truthful with themselves separating
the business from what he wants to do
and saying I like hip-hop I think I want
to rap I don't want to stand on stage
and do that every night so I'm going to
go off and do my own thing he's already
like he's growing his beard again and he
was spotted smoking a cigarette so I
think he's sort of that chance to let
loose a bit and also leaving a group Top
Gear's Jeremy Clarkson the
director-general of the BBC has not
renewed his contract I mean what's the
latest on how where the shows going to
go where Jeremy Clarkson's going to go I
think yeah Clarkson's still been quite
quiet on the issue it was this big build
about whether he go he had to go we knew
that was always going to happen I guess
attention now turns to whether Hammond
and may go it looks at the moment that
they will go and not be a part of the
top gear brand or more interestingly
from media point of view where will the
trio if they go as a true end up there
was talk about Netflix you know this we
talk about it constantly this new way of
delivering TV will they go in that
direction and who will replace them on
top gear because that's a tough gig to
fill yeah Chris Evans was the favorite
he's already ruled in 73 himself
farthing but Nick Knowles now Jodie Kidd
interestingly going done a FEMA angee
ugh angle and Stephen Fry was the the
other options so it's in the mixer
ideally it would be very different i say
that it's the heat thanks very much now
the trial of amanda knox and raffaele
select cheeto for the murder of british
student meredith kercher has been an
enduring source of media fascination
with a case back in the headlines this
week the release of a film inspired by
the story has proved timely Michael
Winterbottom's the face of an angel
looks at how news coverage can influence
public perception they're innocent with
a guilty and you can't be neutral and I
think of a face of an angel I was
with Johnny Jessica she's the story
night Jessica I court it was made very
simple Jessica was the bad girl and
Elizabeth was a good girl Michael lovely
to see thank you so much for coming on
and now the film is based on the
meredith kercher case but is more about
the media's portrayal of the case is
that fair yeah I think so i think it's
the the starting point was the media's
coverage there's a massive amount
coverage besides the news and the the
press there was I think so 10 books
written about it there's five or six TV
documentaries so it was one of those
cases that sort of seemed to capture
people's imagination so the stipend for
them is why does the press spend so much
time on a story like that why do we all
spend so much time watching and reading
stories like that and did you come to a
conclusion not what I do way not really
I mean obviously there are lots of kind
of obvious factors that are involved in
that but I suppose from my point view I
think one fight which isn't so obvious
is that the press has a huge amount of
space to fill you know and I think with
these kind of trials that they become
sort of soap operas and from the press
point of your TV's point of view it's
greatly get a story which can run around
it becomes the characters become like
soap opera kind of characters and you
can gossip about what happened there's
always speculation so I think that is
the one of the bad aspects of it that
that really a really important terrible
story becomes trivialized and why did
you decide to make a fictional film
about it why did you not do a
documentary if you were looking about
looking at the media's portrayal of the
case because it would have worked very
well as a documentary wouldn't it well I
guess I think it's like I think fiction
sometimes can be more intimate than the
documentary you know you can you can
tell the facts of a story document it's
hard sometimes to really see people in
their kind of private moments it's hard
see people behaving badly it's hard to
sort of see people's kind of emotions
and and although the film starts as
being about the press and the kind of
jen is covering the case i can i hope by
the end of the film what people are
thinking about is just it's a heart of a
story like this at the heart of this
specific story a girl are being killed
the girl lost her life she was a kind of
young girl that gone to Italy a few
weeks before full of optimism and join
you're excited for the year
head and then whatever happened that
night you know the simple truth is she
lost the life she's lost all the chance
for happiness her pet family had lost
their daughter their sister and so that
aspect of story I hope is like stronger
in our film that it then ascent Lee was
in the press coverage Berg then it might
be easy to do the documentary so you're
dealing with very delicate subject
matters you're dealing with with real
life characters a family who tragically
lost their daughter and how did you deal
with all those aspects of things well
it's difficult I think I don't a lot of
films based on real people's stories and
you obviously have to treat them with
respect I mean in this case yeah it's
particularly difficult because it
because it's about a murder yeah and
what in the in the practical way what we
did was all the elements of the case the
investigation the trial are exactly the
same as the original story the kit the
murder of meredith kercher so we were
very faithful to exactly what happened
in that area and then around that we
have a kind of the world in the
fictional film of the of our characters
and it's about in a way the parallels
between their lives and the lives of the
people in the story that they're
covering one of your stars is cara
delevingne here we know mainly as a
model she's a bit of a find isn't she
she's great she was fantastic and yeah
I've met a lot of really good actors for
that part before I met Cara and yeah
that I don't really found the right
person and then Kyra walked in the door
and it was like in the morning she'd
flown over night from the Caribbean or
somewhere glamorous and can I came into
the room full of energy and like was
really direct and open I kind of meet
the new she was right for the part yes
she plays the British students and she's
supposed to sort of embody all the good
things about life that when you're young
you're full of energy and optimism and
joy and stuff I talking of someone else
with a lot of energy and you're working
also with Russell Brand at the moment
what can people expect cuz this is a
documentary about the financial crisis
out before the election sounds very very
interesting it's been fun to know
Russell's really kind of great person
he's full you know he as you say is for
veggie he's really committed to like
getting involved in what's going on yeah
yeah I'm sure you notice that he's got
ongoing kind of news alternative to the
scan years the truths and well he's
telling us that no one should vote
dismay well that's not I don't think
that's fair that's really not the
message of our film and it's not a
Denise at work I think it's really
unfair caricature of Russell position
that he goes hunting people not so white
he tells people do is get involved a
active you know you want you want to do
so bad it get up and get home so no
reason no it's not essentially saying
you eat weight has said it's like you
know if you look at the partitions which
one of these would you vote for I think
that's a pretty fair criticism but is
the object that suggests it's going on
saying don't you don't you know don't
care about the world don't care about
what's going around you don't care about
politics he's actually saying gay become
genuinely involved is he hard to wet it
see how about it it's not a as well well
we look forward to it thank you so much
for your time like winter Lawson thank
you thanks now for an actor who most
famously played a gladiator you wouldn't
think there was much that could scare
Russell Crowe but when he stepped behind
the camera to direct his first feature
film the water diviner he found his
nerves or put to the test donec outlook
went to meet him
hey what's the magic word the one that
makes the car before bed tango you've
done close to 50 million trying to toss
now I mean I think it is actually 50 is
there now 50 yeah well there's some some
films that I've done that people don't
know about okay well here we go there
but you've done 50 that we know if I was
young I needed the money love you know
but I mean my 19 year apprenticeship
between the age of six and twenty five
before I actually got lead roles in
films you know I was an extra you know
in many situations even though you know
how to talk this language you know how
films that works you know how films work
was there still that sense of
trepidation from call first day before
we started three or four days before the
shoot started you know ah but you just
you questioning yourself on such a base
level you know such a deep level you're
going I can't get away with this you
know will that thing that ease that I've
always had with film crews and camera
crews will that change now that I'm
actually the boss you know so I was
viewed you know nervous beyond belief
like that level of stage fright couldn't
imagine you know yeah it was a
continuous thing where you know you're
always wondering whether you measure up
the Ducks you know to me I've come to
learn that you know that nerves those
butterflies that stage fright is a
simple indication that you care deeply
about what you're doing obviously got my
own perspective I always have and some
of the directors that I've worked with
particularly probably Ridley Scott and
Ron Howard you know I know there's
elements of what they do that it is in a
way influenced by me and what we could
achieve together what we have achieved
together you know I'm doing things on on
film sets that you know we're cemented
in place in my mind 25 years ago you
know well I know right that's the way
you do this that's the way you
communicate with actors this is the way
you create an intimacy in a bond you
know and a level of trust but you know
it's also times when you're on a film
set man where you're looking at somebody
doing something and you're going to
yourself I am learning right now that
what that person is doing is something
that I will never do on a film
so yeah you take the good with the bad
you know what's the future is finally
acting directing both look man I used to
think at the greatest job in the world
and then I discovered this so you know
if if it was up to me there would never
be another movie that I'm just acting
you know it's a funny thing because I
love my job you know but I love this job
more coming up is there still magic left
in Cinderella will be reviewing it and
the rest of the weekends movies Nick
Broomfield is best known for
documentaries on some of the most famous
and infamous names in popular culture
but away from films about Courtney Love
sarah palin and 2pac he's explored the
dark heart of modern America his latest
project tales of the Grim Sleeper is the
story of a serial killer who went
undetected on the impoverished streets
of South Central LA it is thought Lonnie
might have killed more than a hundred
women over 25 year period I wondered how
this was possible hi so you saw him the
night before he was arrested yeah I
think know before we was talking he was
at dawn I told him I was gonna go
clubbing well I got in about three woke
up about serving the whole street was
blocked off
think I'll know where to let strangers
closed off I mean he was a nice man Nick
lovely to see you yeah now tell me about
this documentary why did you decide to
pick this topic why this story that you
wants to tell it was such an amazing
story I think that over 25 years
somebody was able to kill I mean they
think maybe over a hundred women sort of
completely undetected and when he was
detected it was by a computer of course
him it wasn't sort of intrepid police
work it was a computer matched his DNA
or actually matched his son's DNA to
some of the DNA found on the victims
they worked out the Sun was too young to
have done many of the murders which went
back to sort of 1985 so they worked out
it must have been Lonnie and they
followed him to a pizza place and grab
managed to get a bit of his discarded
pizza and then match the DNA are so it
wasn't as though the police had been
actively pursuing him and found him by
some way or you know was it was when he
was finally caught after 25 years it was
kind of an accident so I mean you live
there it is it like two cities living
side by what it is it's two very
different cities I mean not only have
they vastly different employment rates I
mean it's a lot eighty percent
unemployment in south central is
incredible obesity people die about 25
years younger than any other part of Los
Angeles so it's just very and I think
the the rift has gotten much worse I
think yeah all the federal funding has
been cut off so it's very hard for
people to get out of that it's very hard
for people for example to sell their
houses because their houses are worth
virtually nothing no one wants to move
into the area so they can't really move
out so people are stuck in that
community for years and years and years
and I think you know it was a timely
film to make because obviously with
Ferguson and some of the other things
happening there is an awareness that
there is a kind of
analyzed negligence you know if you
haven't got money you know and you don't
matter nothing very much happens how do
you stay sort of objective in some ways
because you obviously really like the
people in this room you didn't like
Sarah Palin you didn't like Courtney
Love how do you kind of tell the story
how does it how does it change when you
like the subjects involved well I mean
it's a lot it's obviously a lot more fun
to make films about people you like and
it's you know you enjoy spending time
with them and I think there's more of a
rapport and you learn things I mean I
think the film about courtly love that
was really more a film about all the
attempts at corporate America kind of
you know it was like because Kurt was
worth so much money and he was on the
Time Warner label and he was also part
of MTV and he was I was losing half my
funding during the making of the film
you know I remember MTV pulled out
because Courtney was putting pressure on
there but yeah so it became a film more
about you know how difficult is to make
a film about somebody who's very famous
who's worth a great deal of money
because nearly all the companies are
invested in their success so you know
it's easy to make it from about these
kinds of people but you know tell Zach
REM sleep which is a poor community
completely unrepresented but it's very
difficult to make a sort of brutally
honest film about somebody who's worth a
great deal of money like you know the
kurt cobain's or the court news and i
would think with the losses the films
you may you think I couldn't make this
up yeah I think each film is sort of an
adventure I mean you think you know why
you're making at the beginning but
you've got no idea how it's going to end
up and I think you know tells the Grim
Sleeper was surprising about that i mean
i didn't really know whether he was
innocent or guilty i didn't really know
very much about the community i had no
you don't know what characters you're
going to meet and I think what is so
interesting if you have the privilege to
be able to make films in this way is
that you can take an audience on this
incredible advance
sure to meet all these incredible
characters that they would never imagine
meeting it's totally fascinating thank
you so much you don't you time now to
see what's on earth of the movies at
this weekend and the big release is
Disney's remake of Cinderella remember
the magic will only last so long with a
last echo of the last bell but the last
stroke of midnight the spell will be
broken and all will return to what it
was before midnight hmm midnight that's
more than enough time don't you thank
you kuzey yo
and I'm doing now by the film critic
Jason Solomon's lovely to see now Lily
James is Cinderella and the most column
enters have gone to the size of her
waist yes and which is a bit of a waste
to be honest because there's a lot else
to talk about I didn't think she was too
thin if that's anything to go by but you
know what fairy tale heroines you know
what are we supposed to do in the modern
days I supposed to kind of live up to
those kind of froze and ideals of Anna
and her sister and you know while we
remaking something from the 1950s it's
got the talking mice everything that you
wanted in your Disney movie is in here
too and it's directed by kenneth branagh
and i think he's done a very nice job
with it I mean it's kind of like him
doing panto a bit so yeah I really felt
like you know there was you know
Christmas he feel to it because it has
the magic but you know Lily James is
faintly annoying as Cinderella to be
honest but I think that's the part
that's quite the way it is what you
really watch it for us for the
incidental stuff the costumes by sending
power charm magnificent and the people
my father's the fairy godmother and Cate
Blanchett as the sort of evil stepmother
who is brilliant I mean that the film
picks up immensely when those two are on
the screen as the Disney film does to
you know the devil always gets the best
lines of the Disney movies and the fairy
godmothers great bibbidi-bobbidi-boo in
Cinderella the mice are pretty good too
this is done fantastically at the
American box office in particular maybe
because I mean the preamble to the film
is a frozen shorts that's right frozen
fever which everyone's desperate for
frozen too and they said that they're
gonna be tellin ya photo is coming but
to kind of like eight that massive
audience the biggest cartoon of all time
they put it at the front of Cinderella
frozen fever a little short it's
delightful it's really fun face of an
angel is probably you probably are the
audience for this did you like it thanks
evangel is Michael Winterbottom's study
kind of take on the meredith kercher
Amanda Knox case except it's not it's
not about that it's not even set in
perugia it's set in Siena just down the
road it's a thinly veiled kind of look
at what happened in this case at how the
media have taken it but the filmmakers
they like Michael Winterbottom making it
a film how difficult it is to get to the
truth of this I think it's very
interesting take on these kind of big
murder cases how we also take sides and
how different newspapers text size and
different website to take sides and of
course you've now got the extra layer of
Michael Winterbottom the filmmaker
taking sighs he's one of the only
filmmakers that could make a murder
trial about a sort of dead in English
girl all about himself finally seventh
son now before we hear from you let's
take a look did you miss me you have
haven't you don't try to deny it I can
see into your soul
Wow
so this is Julia more fresh from her
Oscar win in what looks like what I
don't know you describe it to me dragons
everything looks a bit like game of
throne I've seen it I still don't know
what it's about it's good thank God you
know you win an Oscar and sometimes it's
the crowning glory of your career
sometimes it's a curse you know Jeff
Bridges is in this as well you want an
Oscar for crazy hasn't been in a decent
movie since what happens is your price
goes up so all those cool indie movies
that you were doing all the way up till
you get your Oscar you now they can't
now afford you so your agent dumps you
in these big blockbusters because your
name sells these tickets and you end up
in nonsense I can't understand what
you're talking about Jeff Bridges sounds
like he's doing Winston Churchill doing
an impression of Yoda Julianne Moore's
like a witch with eyes and hair and
there's monsters and Dragons it is
absolute nonsense about no i did in
German Hans who turns out everyone runs
away Olivia Williams her that were an
sto this even real hot yeah she's having
this and looks completely lost in this
and she's kind of got this bump some
outfit on and she's not back summer to
it so it's a real miss ben barnes is
really boring in it it sounds absolutely
appalled i mean i wish i knew what was
going on I do not know I head nor tail
and Julianne Moore has got a tail in
this film and that kills people I don't
know what it was about it's a seventh
son it just about goes time to and a
demon it's as if they were just get on
with it you've got Julianne Moore go
sell some tickets I don't I think it's a
disaster it so it's really horrible film
that sounds horrendous well it sounds
like your pic of the week you're
definitely Cinderella learn well I know
that sounds a bit kind of girly but but
yeah I enjoyed it will go that would
thank you so much Jason and that is all
for this week if you've missed any of
the show it's available anytime on catch
up see you next time
you